stat news I hate to end on a down note  but that high those high winds on this  weekend brought down a two hundred and  twenty seven-year-old tree but not just  any tree a tree planted in 1791 by  George Washington himself that stood  over his tomb for 227 years it turns out  it just took fifty to sixty mile an hour  winds to take down the Canadian hemlock  and Virginia cedar it stands no more a  plaque was on that tree Washington knew  about the tree but he is not he did not  outlive the tree  I guess the rocking-chair you know it's  good lemons lemonade you know what I was  trying to get home again and the trains  weren't running the planes weren't  flying I got in a car and because of the  high winds the bridges were closed you  couldn't go up and down these great  story one hour